اسماعيل اذا اخر التطورات فيما يتعلق
بتحركات الجيش وايضا الاخبار الوارده حول
اطلاق النار و قصف خيام للنازحين في
المواصي نعم هذه المنطقه التي حددتها قوات
الاحتلال بانها منطقه امنه وحدث مسار
للنازحين للتحرك من هذا الشارع الذي يعرف
بشارع خمسه باتجاه منطقه شارع الرشيد على
شاطئ بحر خان يونس حيث يتحرك النازحون
باتجاه شارع البحر ومن ثم التوجه الى اما
وسط قطاع غزه باتجاه دير البلح او حتى
جنوبا في مدينه رفح لكن اليات الاحتلال
خلال هذه الليله وفجر هذا اليوم قطعت هذا
الشاعر الشارع وثم انطلقت وتوجهت باتجاه
الشارع الرشيد الذي هو شارع البحر في تلك
المنطقه وقامت باطلاق النار باتجاه سياره
مدنيه في تلك على شارع الرشيد حيث تفاجا
المواطنون الذين كانوا ينوون التحرك
باتجاه منطقه رفح بدبابات الاحتلال على
شارع الرشيد وهو شارع البحر ومن ثم اطلقت
هذه الدبابه النار باتجاه هذه السياره
المدنيه ما ادى الى ارتقاء اربعه شهداء في
السياره تم نقل هؤلاء الشهداء باتجاه
مستشفى ابو يوسف النجار في مدينه رفح
اضافه الى ذلك بان دبابات الاحتلال قامت
باطلاق قذائف مدفعيه باتجاه خيام النازحين
في منطقه المواصي والتي ايضا حددها
الاحتلال بانها منطقه امنه وايضا طلب من
المواطنين التوجه الى تلك المناطق على
اعتبار انها امنه كما وصف الاحتلال لكن تم
صف هذه المنطقه من قبل دبابات الاحتلال
واطلقت قذائفها باتجاه هذه الخيام ادى ذلك
الى ارتقاء اربعه شهداء ايضا من احدى
العائلات الفلسطينيه التي كانت تاوي في
تلك المنطقه اضافه الى عمليات اطلاق نار
بشكل مباشر تهدد حياه المواطنين الذين
كانوا في تلك المنطقه حركه النزوح بشكل
كبير في هذه اللحظات في محافظه خانيونس
لكن التحرك في هذه اللحظات من شارع خمسه
هناك خطوره بالغه وشديده جدا على حياه
المواطنين الذين يتحركون خاصه ان اليات
الاحتلال تتمركز وتتواجد في تلك المنطقه
وتقوم باطلاق النار بين الحين والاخر ايضا
الغارات لا تتوقف والقصف المدفعي لا يتوقف
في محيط المنطقه كذلك الى الشرق من تلك
المنطقه القصف مستمر ومتواصل واطلاق النار
متواصل شارع خمسه حاليا تحديدا يصعب على
المواطنين سلوكه لكن يتجهون يقطعون هذا
الشارع باتجاه الشمال من اجل سلوك شوارع
فرعيه والتفافه للوصول الى شارع الرشيد ال
الذي انسحبت منهه اليات الاحتلال الفجر
هذا اليوم وعادت الى منطقه شارع خمسه
تحديدا بالقرب من منطقه الصناعه والان
يتوجه المواطنون باتجاه هذا الشارع تحديدا
شوارع التفاف من اقصى الشمال لمدينه اصداء
ومن ثم يتوجهون الى المنطقه الغربيه وكذلك
يسلكون الشارع الرشي هذه نقطه مهمه تحتاج
لتوضيح اسماعيل فيما تبقى من من وقت
لاماكن تمركز الاليات وان كان شارع الرشيد
شارع البحر هو مفتوح طبعا شمالا جنوبا في
الاتجاهين نعم الشارع مفتوح لكن مفتوح من
الجنوب باتجاه الشمال شمال جنوب في
الاتجاه المفتوح لكن من الناحيه الشرقيه
لهذا الشارع وهي يمتد في امتداده شارع
خمسه وكذلك شوارع اخرى من مدينه خانيونس
هذه الشوارع فيها خطوره في حركه المواطنين
خاصه ان اعداد النازحين بشكل كبير من خان
يونس يحتاج المواطنون والنازحون للتحرك
باتجاه شارع الرشيد ان
يعني يعني يسلك طرق التفافا وكذلك يبتعدوا
عن مصادر اطلاق النار ومصادر الخطوره التي
تقوم طا اليات الاحتلال وكذلك دبابات
الاحتلال باطلاق النار في المنطقه ومن ثم
يتوجهون الى شارع الرشيد حتى يتمكنوا من
التوجه سواء الى المطقه الوسطى في وسط
قطاع غزه او حتى المنطقه الجنوبيه في
مدينه في مدينه رفح لكن قبل قليل تحدثنا
مع بعض المصادر في تلك المنطقه تحدثوا بان
قوات الاحتلال ما زالت تطلق النار
والمواطنون والنازحون بعضهم يجازف والدخول
يدخلون في في تلك الشوارع وينجحوا في
الوصول الى شارع الرشيد ومن ثم يتجهون الى
مناطق اكثر امنا وبعض المواطنين لا يستطيع
المجازفه في ظل هذه الظروف عمليات اطلاق
النار المستمره فيعود ادراجه الى منطقه
خانيونس حيث منطقه المعسكر ومنطقه المشروع
حي الامل وكذلك المدارس التي تاوي نازحين
في محيط مستشفى ناصر كل هذه المناطق ماز
ما زالت مكتظه بالسكان ويتواجد المواطنون
ولا يعلمون اي الطرق التي يسلكون حتى يامن
على حياتهم في ظل هذا التصعيد الاسرائيلي
المستمر من قبل اليات الاحتلال وتطلق
نيرانها باتجاه كل ما هو متحرك في تلك
المنطقه